bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat retour cet après midi
sur les auditions de la commission des
lois sur le mariage pour tous mardi à
les sénateurs ont entendu les
représentants de l'association des
maires de france mais également de
l'association des départements de france
donc sans plus tarder ces auditions mes
chers collègues
bonjour nous deux en amont notre
troisième semaine d'auditions sur ce
texte sur le mariage pour tous vous
voyez que le sénat a décidé
et d'ailleurs cela a été remarquée de
passer beaucoup de temps à auditionner
les hautes personnalités qui nous font
l'honneur de venir nous rencontrer et
avec le temps nécessaire c'est à dire
que monsieur le président ici il ya le
temps c'est très important sur des
sujets de grande importance
donc je suis
nous allons on peut entendre eux
d'autres personnalités
cet après midi bien sûr monsieur le
président de l'association des maires de
france dont je vais parler dans un
instant puis monsieur guedj qui
représentera l'association des
départements de france et à 16h30 nous
recevrons les deux ministres concernés
par ce texte
madame christiane taubira et madame
dominique bertinotti eux
alors je suis très heureux d'accueillir
jacques pélissard eux qui est venu
accompagné de madame geneviève serre et
de monsieur touzet janvier
alexandre touzet je suis très heureux
d'accueillir monsieur le président de
l'association des maires de france
parce que bien qu'ils soient députés et
ne prenez pas cette proposition
circonstancielle de concession de
manière négative
il n'ignore pas que la constitution a
prévu que le sénat représente les
collectivités territoriales de la
république
j'ajoute aussitôt que nous n'avons
jamais eu en tout cas pour ma part je
n'ai jamais eu de vision restrictive de
cela et je pense que l'assemblée
nationale a évidemment toute légitimité
pour traiter des collectivités
territoriales de la république elle
aussi mais je veux dire à monsieur le
président de la mfr je pense avec votre
accord certainement mes chers collègues
sinon vous aurez la possibilité de
protester mais que monsieur pélissard
est chez lui ici que nous sommes heureux
de l'accueillir parce que le président
d'une association qui compte trente six
mille 700 maires est pour nous un
personnage très important je voulais
ajouter monsieur pélissard que nous
avons eu l'honneur de travailler à
certaines propositions de loi qui ont
été adoptées par le sénat et par
l'assemblée nationale
signe que l'on peut et devrait sur des
sujets concernant les collectivités
locales qui rassemble et que deux encore
récemment le sénat parce qu'on parle
parfois je parle devant mes collègues on
parle parfois de textes qui ne trouve
pas de majorité au sénat bien ça tient à
la configuration du sénat aux enjeux
politiques
mais on oublie parfois de dire que
certains textes sont votés et bien voté
par le sénat
ainsi une loi sur les conditions
d'exercice des mandats locaux une
proposition de loi
qui a été écrite par notre collègue
genting gouro vice président de
l'association des maires de france par
votre serviteur une autre sur une
autorité relatives aux normes ont été
votés à l'unanimité
ainsi je profite de votre présence bien
que ça n'a rien à voir avec le sujet qui
nous qui nous unit qui nous réunissent
cet après-midi pour vous dire que nous
serions bien sûr attaché et je pense
aussi l'association des maires de france
à ce que ces projets de propositions
doit suivre leurs cours parlementaire
enrichi de tout ce que pourra apporter
l'assemblée nationale est ce que de ce
que pourra apporter en particulier la m
est bien alors maintenant nous sommes
réunis pour parler du mariage pour tous
et je vais vous proposer cher président
et cher collègue de nous faire un exposé
introductif si vous le voulez bien
à la suite de quoi je donnerai la parole
à nos deux brillants rapporteur parce
que nous avons deux rapporteurs qui sur
ce texte je dois le dire se donne
beaucoup de mal
monsieur jean pierre michel pour la
commission des lois et madame michelle
meunier pour la commission des affaires
sociales donc je leur donnerai la parole
après monsieur le président et puis
ensuite mes chers collègues vous pourrez
vous exprimer
voilà monsieur le président merci
monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur mam le rapporteur cherche les
parlementaires messieurs les sénateurs
le tien vêtements avant massif devant
façon luminaires pour leur accueil c'est
vrai que nous avons eu donc du travail
en commun des textes en commun et noah
qui m nous donnons sa collègue d'une
proposition de loi sur les cdc qui a été
votée effectivement à une période où la
majorité était différente au sénat et à
l'assemblée ce qui montre que c'était un
texte qui rencontrait donc une volonté
de parvenir à son aboutissement vous
dire que pour la loi donc la proposition
de loi déposée par way monsieur
président et par mam courau sur les
normes d'une part et sur le statut d'élu
championnat le texte est bon a pas mes
forces a effectivement s'est échouée au
bureau de l'association des maires de
france à permettre un cheminement
efficace donc devant l'assemblée
nationale
vous dire que je suis très heureux
d'être auditionnés par votre commission
sur la question du mariage pour tous
avec une observation liminaire encore à
faire l'association des maires de france
que je préside est une association les
dix mesures région qui regroupe tous les
maires de france avec leur sensibilité
donc j'avais dit aussi devant le présent
publique monsieur françois hollande qui
était venu à notre congrès des maires en
novembre 2012
mf ne prend pas position sur le fond du
texte
chaque maire chaque député maire c'est
encore possible
chaque sénateur maire a appliqué la loi
comme il l'entend mais je l'avais dit
nous marions au nom de la loi
souvenez vous la formule officielle au
nom de la loi je vous déclare unis par
le mariage donc mariant au nom de la loi
les maires respecteront la loi et ce que
j'ai dit à ma moto dira quand elle m'a
reçu je vais dire également commission
des lois de l'assemblée
c'est par contre le rôle la mfc que
permettre que soient respectés deux
choses la loi d'une part mais aussi la
conscience des mers et sur ce registre
j'avais déposé et présenté trois
amendements devant la commission des
lois et devant le l'assemblée sur les
trois thèmes suivants le premier est
simple d'ailleurs c'est monsieur
présidente monsieur monsieur leur porter
mais sur les reporter le seul amendement
quasiment qui avaient été réalisés ces
amendements sur le lieu de mariage
l'élargissement du jeu du mariage ça a
été les gens à voter on était dans une
situation en permettant une sortie d'
hypocrisie on doit en principe se marier
son lieu de résidence mais on sait tous
on peut voir des mariages sur alizé
mieux domicile des parents de l'un des
parents des parents
donc ne peuvent être nombreux et s'ils
sont séparés bref aujourd'hui
d'amendements accepté et voter vos sims
prison l unanimité par l'assemblée
nationale permet d'élargir le périmètre
c'est bien sûr le lieu où l'on habite
mais aussi soi peut être le lieu où
habite l'un des parents
une du couple et ça vaut bien sûr pour
les couples hétérosexuels comme pour les
couples homosexuels
donc sur ce point je n'ai rien pas
simplement une ride prière c'est que le
sénat donc maintiennent cet amendement
voté à l'unanimité avec salon le l'ajout
du rapporteur disons que c'est bien sûr
à la demande des époux
elles montrent des difficultés que le le
choix de telle ou telle commune se fait
premier amendement deuxième et plus plus
important il n'a pas été votée il est
est englobée dans une enveloppe en une
la snia ce de tous les amendements
hostile au mariage avec le principe la
clause de conscience
très franchement moi je n'ai jamais
utilisé le mot clause de conscience
chacun a sa conscience même aux clauses
ou liberté devant le président éric je
n'avais pas utilisé lui d'ailleurs son
médecin l'avait utilisée avant de se
rétracter
mais notre position est claire il faut
respecter la loi j'ai dit est respecté a
conscience d'eux-mêmes et pour ce faire
il faut mieux organiser le principe des
délégations
aujourd'hui vous connaissez le droit
positif et délégation c'est la
possibilité de léguer un conseiller
municipal et 7 juin sont eux-mêmes
visite à civile que celui de télé y est
de veiller un conseil municipal lorsque
le maire est absent ou empêché et on
assiste là encore à des situations
totalement hypocrite où ça m'était
arrivé aussi pour mme avec une nuance
que j'exprimerai pour déléguer un
conseil municipal qui veut marier son
fils ou sa fille
le maire ne peut pas être présent si
même ce sont des amis qui se marie moi
quand j'espère j'espère respecter la loi
quand je délègue à un conseiller une
conseillère de suite et de marier son
enfant je suis absent parce qu'on veut
pas être délégataire est présent donc il
faut à mon sens préciser les choses
ouvry avoir une approche le noni
hypocrite dans la loi dix ans le maire
peut déléguer sous son contrôle
à telle ou telle qu'on s'émancipe aux
municipales et pour une opération
spécifique du mariage de tel ou tel
ça c'est une vraie délégation parce que
monsieur le président monsieur les
reporter on est aujourd'hui dans les
poésies la plus complète aujourd'hui
dans des grandes villes par exemple il y
à des délégations permanentes à des
conseillers municipaux pour marié à tour
de rôle avec des dates précises telles
samedi 1er samedi sa troisième asie
alors qu'en fait c'est pas possible
la délégation est forcément spécifique
ne pas dire une délégation générale
un conseil municipal avec un maire
absent empêcher qui peut un jour
peut-être un tel ou tel contexte être
l'objet d'une contestation judiciaire
je crois qu'il faut dire je simplement
correspondant la vérité le maire peut
déléguer un conseiller municipal pour le
soin de procéder at elle été mariage
points évacuons la notion de malades ont
empêché ou on tombe forcément dans le
mensonge ou l'hypocrise deuxième
amendement que j'ai présentés puis
troisième en mon nom je dis il paraît
nécessaire
pourquoi deux principes respect de la
loi et respect la confiance des désirs
si un maire ne veut pas mariés s'il
délègue en cascade si je puis dire à
tous les élus de son camp principal dans
un petit conseil municipal de 2 9 11
membres ça peut se produire et que tout
le monde refuse il faut que force reste
à la loi
il ya un sondage récent qui sortit
faisant apparaître que 29% des mères
étaient très défavorables loi et que 23
% étaient défavorables
ça fait cinquante deux donc qu' on
risque d'avoir les situations tout le
monde déclinera la possibilité de marie
et à ce pont là il me paraît normal
normal c'est dans notre droit positif là
encore que le procureur public puisse
donner instruction marié sait
aujourd'hui ce qui se passe quand on a
un souci par exemple soit possibilité de
marier un ou une française par exemple
avec un étranger en situation
irrégulière
on sollicite l'avis du procureur public
procureur nous donne instruction et on
se
conforme à ses instructions ça me
paraîtrait normal parce qu'ils perdent
et cathy gurs non pas uniquement pour
des mariages homosexuels mais aussi par
exemple un vieux monsieur qui épouse une
jeune femme peu importe et des cas de
figure où la l'instruction peut émaner
peu thème année du programme amériques
voilà les trois amendements que j'ai
présentés l'un était satisfait le
deuxième très franchement me paraît pas
poser de problème particulier
c'est simplement l'ouverture de la
délégation pour tous les mariages pour
son mariage bien su alors toutes les
villas toutes les communes quelle que
soit leur taille
puis le troisième c'est prévoir un
taquet si je puis dire pour que la loi
soit fiction respecté et que healy
instructions données
si par impossible si c'est impossible
dans tous les conseils municipaux
il y avait donc désistement en cascade
par rapport à la délégation donnée par
monsieur le président monsieur à porter
même la rapporteure pour avis ce que je
tenais à exprimer de façon liminaire
face à ce texte ou les mères sont
respectueux la loi mais je les dis il
faut que la loi permette aussi le
respect de leur conscience
merci monsieur le président je pense que
s'agissant de votre second amendement
il s'agit en effet de de fer que le
droit correspondent à ce qui est
pratiqué dans un grand nombre de mairies
c'est la réalité bien alors je donne
tout de suite la parole à monsieur jean
pierre michel rapporteur pour la
commission des lois
merci le président merci merci monsieur
monsieur bizarre de votre bon moi je
dois dire que ce que voulaient de dire
me convient assez bien
on m'avait entendue comme ça d'autres
choses qu'il peut pas être accepté par
exemple qu'on aurait inscrit dans la loi
une pause de conscience des mers bon il
ya une clause de conscience des médecins
en ce qui concerne l'avortement par
exemple mon les médecins de la
profession libérale bon les maires sont
des fichiers d'état civil
comme vous l'avez dit fort bien monsieur
le président ils doivent appliquer la
loi point final
donc dès l'instant où
je dirais il n'y a pas de sous-entendus
mais je pense pas qu'ils amenez vos
premiers amendements on a déjà vu
puisque on a déjà fait une réunion un
peu de coordination avec mon collègue la
forme et national bon cet amendement il
sera une phrase maintenu il entendu
quant aux deux aux deux suivants bon
sous réserve que tout ça soit accepté et
c'est moi il me pose pas de gros
problèmes on dira que reprécisant un
texte qu'à l'occasion de tous les
mariages les délégations ne l'avait
donné à chaque fois d'ailleurs dans les
grandes villes allégations général je ne
sais dans nos communes moyennes la
mienne avant ou qua non chaque fois là
la secrétaire de l'état civil téléphone
mais c'est le maire il ya tellement de
faire ou pas alors je peux je ne suis
pas là très bien on va saisir le premier
adjoint y les palabres et à peu en une
délégation chaque fois j'ai entendu bon
qu on précisera dans la loi votée dans
la loi
alors là et puis ensuite on verra le
texte que vous avez qu'on dise que
lorsqu'il ya une difficulté et une
instruction du procureur de la
république
elle existe déjà fait instruction
puisque aujourd'hui on peut c'est sur le
programme réduit lorsqu'on a un doute je
me souviens bien notamment pour des
mariages avec des étrangers sans pas qui
a vraiment peu importe les difficultés
comme ça et quand le procureur donne
il donne pas son avis il donne une
instruction vous marier ou vous ne
pouvez pas mariés voilà donc sous
réserve de l'examen plus approfondie de
vos amants de la réaction de vos
amendements sur le fond moi ça ne pose
pas de gros problème voilà et je dirais
alors ça puisqu'on peut parler politique
aussi que sur un plan politique
bon le gouvernement à déposer ce texte
des parties des propositions d présente
la république
si l'on doit paraître nombre
d'amendements je dirais je dirais non
pas satisfaire mais rassuré un certain
nombre de collègues maires nous sommes
sans tout à fait bien
et le monsieur michel madame michelle
meunier rapporteur pour la commission
des affaires sociales merci monsieur le
président écoute et une fois n'est pas
coutume moi je n'ai pas forcément de
questions à poser au président pélissard
puisque vous êtes venu présenter les
amendements que vous avez défendu à
l'assemblée nationale donc de ma place
rapporteur pour avis de la commission
des affaires sociales je n'ai pas
forcément l'espace pour questionner ni
commenter si ce n'est vous donner
peut-être un témoignage puisque j'étais
pendant 22 ans adjointe au maire de
nantes et que je me souviens très bien
être de permanence comme tous mes
collègues et peut-être même parfois
demandant du renfort quand on avait plus
de quinze mariages assuré matin ou
l'après midi donc voilà pour donner un
peu d'humanité à tout ça voilà mais ça
se passait comme vous l'avez dit
d'ailleurs que j'ai fait aussi beaucoup
de mariages dans ma vie et en tant que
mère et je trouve que c'est toujours un
moment tout à fait satisfaisant pour les
élus car quand les gens viennent pour se
marier à la mairie
ils sont contents en arrivant et ils
sont également content en repartant
tandis que dans les autres circonstances
il arrive qu'ils viennent mécontents et
qu'il ressorte content il arrive qu'ils
viennent y contents ils ressortent
mécontents ils arrivent le pire c'est
qu'ils arrivent mécontents et qu'ils
ressortent également mécontents car on
n'a pas pu répondre à leurs attentes
tandis que les mariages
c'est un moment privilégié dans la vie
des élus non ça va ma bonne foi
alors monsieur le président pour
répondre aux rapporteurs braibant deux
rapporteurs après je donnerai la parole
aux autres collègues
monsieur l'emporterait était enfin si je
puis dire exactement que j'ai déposé
que je vais y aller vous a semblé qu'ils
vont être donc soumis à votre commission
des lois ensuite bien sûr au sénat bon
j'ai pas de gestion vertueuse normalise
correspond tout à fait à la mienne par
contre sur surmonte moi j'ai
effectivement eu un autre témoignage
nous trélut nantes qui m'avait édifiant
10 et asocial qui m'avait dit
effectivement que à nantes il y avait
une permanence mais on est jeu édité ya
très gentiment dans l'intimité d'amusant
et lois en étendant les grecs vivent
égalité totale
ça fait rien dans l'activité de tous nos
auditeurs bon mais c'est pas grave
sortir l'été non mais il y a il ya eu il
ya une pratique qui est de bon sens
parce que c'est évident que le maire ne
peut pas faire tous les mariages ni même
souvent les adjoints d'ailleurs dans des
grandes villes où il ya énormément de
mariage et par conséquent se réparti la
tâche avec les collègues eux et adjoints
et conseillers municipaux délégués dos
et la pratique et ça se passe bien donc
votre idée de faire que le droit
rejoignent une pratique qui est accepté
par tout le monde me paraît de bon sens
je pense qu'il ne manquera pas de deux
sénateurs et sénatrices de différentes
tendances pour présenter ces amendements
d'ailleurs beaucoup de sénateurs sont
encore membres de l'association des
maires de france bien alors maintenant
je vais donner la parole à nos collègues
alors oui oui qui veut la parole alors
et
alors d'abord madame qu'hier man ensuite
j'ai monsieur le whip je connais
j'aurais d'ailleurs se seraient pas bien
je ne vous connaissent pas pour beaucoup
de raisons alors après qui veut encore
parlé madame benbassa n'a pas d'idées
monsieur le doyen gélard ne pas de
remarques à nous faire monsieur darniche
non plus jamais ça va peut-être venir
monsieur retailleau bon alors madame du
kerman vous avez la parole oui quelques
quelques remarques sur les propos qui
viennent d'être retenus moi j'entends et
je crois que c'est important
effectivement que finalement les maires
adjoints et conseillers municipaux qui
auront appliqué la loi que je l'espère
nous voterons s'y retrouver puisse la
faire vivre j'ai envie de dire de de la
façon la plus simple possible mois sur
les propositions que vous faites
monsieur pélissard la dernière me pose
mon procès questions sur sur
l'instruction par le procureur de la
république parce que autant j'entends
alors même si les deux premiers
amendements ne sont pas liés à la
question du mariage pour les personnes
du même sexe mais pour faciliter les
mariages de quelque nature qu'il soit il
vient ils viennent quand même dans le
cadre de ce débat là donc ils ne sont
pas je crois
complètement innocent
une fois que tout le monde s'est
déclinée au sein d'un conseil municipal
je crois qu'il faut rappeler aux maires
sont une obligation et s'il n'y a pas de
suspicion sur la légitimité on va dire
du mariage voilà le maire n'a pas pu
donner délégation il lui revient donc à
lui de le faire parce que moi j'entends
qu'il faut respecter la conscience de
chacun le
le choix finalement de chacun y compris
des mères être maire c'est aussi à voir
prendre des responsabilités être tenus à
des obligations que cela nous plaise ou
non et je le dis très très sereinement
mais je trouve que l'on fait aujourd'hui
beaucoup attention et on prend avec
beaucoup de précaution ce débat auprès
de nos collègues maires c'est très bien
je regrette que l'on n'ait pas pris avec
autant de précautions
l'état d'esprit de nos collègues maires
quant à devoir appliquer le service
minimum en cas de grève dans l'éducation
nationale et où effectivement un certain
nombre de nos collègues maires ayez vu
d'ailleurs un congrès des maires assez
tumultueux au monde de ce texte là c'est
pour ça que je fais la comparaison
voilà ont refusé et ne se retrouvent et
pas dans d'autres ce qui leur a été
demandé mais le fond ou alors ne le font
pas mes jambes ça c'est après la
bataille politique
il n'y a pas d' aménagement de la loi
pour permettre à ceux qui voudraient de
pouvoir le faire ou ne pas pouvoir le
faire donc je prends volontairement un
exemple sur un autre champ que celui du
domaine de la vie privée mais parce que
je crois qu'il est il est important de
rester finalement de mettre en avant la
difficulté je crois quand nous sommes
vus et finalement quel que soit le
mandat que mon âme est peut-être encore
plus quand on est maire d'avoir
effectivement bon des obligations
affaires et des choses à mettre en
oeuvre même si on ne partage pas et je
crois que ça c'est dans le quotidien
donc moi sur voilà on va effectivement
il faudrait peut-être qu'on puisse les
meules et travailler et voir mais autant
je vois l'état d'esprit
de celui qui a été adopté à ce national
du deuxième que nous avait présenté
autant soit j'ai pas bien compris mais
j'ai quand même un doute sur sur la
pertinence de la troisième proposition
que vous nous avez fait ici mais le
débat continuera et on leur a jusque
dans la missive jusqu'au mois d'avril
donc tout le temps de trouver les
positionnements
bien monsieur le merci madame qu kerman
monsieur le merci monsieur le président
monsieur le président de la mef je
partage totalement les deux premiers
amendements et je vais revenir sur la
l'aspect délicat de la troisième c'est à
dire de la notion de conscience
qu'est ce qui est du ressort de la
conscience
sûrement pas une divergence d'opinions
politiques
je ne compare pas le non-respect illégal
d'une loi par des maires de ne pas
appliquer par exemple soit soit le
service minimum soit les rythmes futur
rythme scolaire comme étant une clause
de conscience là sommes nous dans ce
débat là dans un domaine qui touche la
conscience non ça la vraie question est
il légitime de demander aux maires afin
de permettre aux verts de d'évoquer une
clause pour une liberté de conscience
pour ma part oui largement mais
effectivement quand j'évoque cela cela
suscite des réactions diverses de
nombreuses lui dise non il n'y a pas du
tout de problème de conscience
il y à la loi à respecter est au fond un
maire se doit de respecter la loi
il ne peut pas se mettre à l'écart est
il donc ce projet de loi du ressort de
la conscience pour ma part je pense oui
et je crois ne pas être le seul à le
penser et je me réfère monsieur le
président aux propos de monsieur le
président de la république devant le
congrès des maires est devant vous suite
à votre intervention
dans son allocution à deux reprises dans
le même texte
il a évoqué la liberté de conscience
dans ce sujet à deux reprises dans le
même discours il a dit et il y a de
toute façon la liberté de conscience
ce qui lui a valu quand même quelques
applaudissements dans la salle il a dit
et puis il y à des délégations
il a ajouté ces délégations sont
extensibles
ça veut dire beaucoup de choses et moi
je voudrais qu'à un revenir sur votre
proposition qui est un pas vers la
reconnaissance de la liberté de
conscience que je souhaite voir inscrite
dans la loi mais je me dis que au fond
la mission des mères la mission
institutionnelle des mers depuis la
révolution depuis la poste évolution
c'est d'avoir un acte d'état
c'est un acte d'état civil quand ils
baril quand ils recueillent les
naissances et quand ils enregistrent les
décès le maire est agent de l'état il a
une délégation première de l'état pour
exercer cette mission
d'ailleurs il n'ya pas que les mères qui
ont cette délégation car à l'étranger ce
sont les ambassadeurs ne sont pas des
mères ce ne sont pas des élus ce sont
des représentants de l'état qui marient
à l'étranger dans les ambassades et donc
je voudrais suggérer que au cas où comme
vous les appelez les délégations en
cascade
fait rarissime mais n'arrivent pas au
bout et j'ai des exemples précis dans
mon département où des petits villages
de neuf conseillers municipaux ont
délibéré à l'unanimité pour refuser le
cas échéant de mariée et pour demander
la clause de conscience au cas où cela
se passe je m'interroge sur la capacité
que la loi aurait de rendre
temporairement et pour ces cas là leur
mission à l'état directement et demandé
à l'administration d'état monsieur le
sous préfet ou à monsieur le préfet
d'organiser à ce moment là le mariage
dans ces lieux de l'état alors cela
suppose une reconnaissance de la
conscience une fois encore comme il me
sens que le président de la république
l'avait reconnu
je le vois pas pourquoi on ne pourrait
pas prendre en contre cette proposition
merci monsieur le je pense que ce sont
donc des questions importantes qui
viennent d'être posés par exemple qui
remanie monsieur le et peut-être mes
chers collègues voudriez vous ajouter
quelque chose pour que monsieur le
président puisse répondre à l'ensemble
que j'ai comme inscrit monsieur michel
madame cuillère man de madame bonne foi
non que personne d'autres parmi nos
collègues non madame où lennon est
arrivé en retard alors madame angot les
passes et a remarqué le président eh
bien c'est fait je vous félicite
voilà alors je donne la parole à
monsieur michel dont je voudrais juste
fait donner un problème de précision à
nos collègues notamment notre collègue
sénateur maire d'arras il ne trompe de
grâce pardon on regarde de grâce bon moi
je comprends cette question mais le
troisième amendement de l'association
des maires et pour partiellement
partiellement par contre dire dans la
loi que dans le cas où les gaz en calcat
denis rey ne ne permettrait pas le
mariage que ce serait le sous préfet par
exemple ou un fonctionnaire qui oserait
marié je trouve que c'est dévaloriser la
fonction de maire et ce ne semble pas
être une bonne chose
je dois dire d'ailleurs que en droit
international comparez vous le verrez
pratiquement la clause de conscience
pour les mères n'est pas admise en
espagne alors à l'espagne on parle tour
d'espagne en espagne le mariage
religieux vaut toujours mariage civil
mais même en espagne
le tribunal suprême a dit une phrase qui
est très forte qui a un devoir
inconditionnels de pays sens au droit de
la part des maires dans les pays
protestant où il ya une religion d'état
en suède au danemark en grande-bretagne
ou en montagne a pas de rien de sexuel
en suède au danemark
bon les ministres du culte alors ils
peuvent faire un mariage civil
en général c'est ce qui se passe les
excès d'églises protestantes
reconnaissent de mariage homosexuel mais
lorsque un pasteur refuse
eh bien on en présente un autre voilà
bon mais le pasteur c'est quand même pas
un maire c'est quand même un membre
d'une église un peu un tout petit peu
différent voilà en belgique bon métier
qu'il n'y a pas de il n'y a pas de
clause de conscience par exemple donc
c'est une question qui a été dans la
tête de tous les états vous les pays où
le mariage a été ouvert aux couples de
même sexe et qui a été résolu par la
négative en ce qui concerne le mariage
purement civil et par des voix un peu
comme ça au blick
lorsque le mariage religieux peut tenir
des mariages civils
donc moi je suis assez sensible ce
président à vos amendements qui
paraissent est une espèce de ligne comme
sa médiane je sais qu'ils ne vont pas
aussi loin que certains ne souhaiterait
qu'ils vont plus loin que d'autres le
souhaiterait peut-être rien mais a
priori comme ça il me semble devoir être
nuit mais on verra
si monsieur le rapporteur madame
cukierman simplement pour pour préciser
ou sur ce qui a été dit après sur la
question de la conscience
je crois que la conscience c'est propre
de chacun effectivement et que autant
même si je ne partage pas cet argument
mais j'entends effectivement que des
individus peuvent avoir leur conscience
qu'ils soient heurtés toucher tous que
tous les termes qu'on veut pour le
qualifier par par cette union mais
laissez-moi le droit aussi de rapporter
que sur d'autres cas les consciences
peuvent être touchées et oui je le dis
de la même façon même ce n'est pas mon
cas mais je l'entends que ça peut
heurter sur une forme d'union
le fait d'être une atteinte au droit de
grève ça peut aussi être être heurté
tout comme un certain nombre d'autres de
dérouler donc ça c'est je crois le cas
de la personne je crois que la
conscience est attaché à la personne et
donc comprendre tous les exemples et
donc moi je pense que quand on devient
élus quand on devient nerfs et un an
reste des êtres humains et ce n'est plus
la personne mais la fonction que l'on
exerce au nom de et je pense que l'on
m'a aussi partir de ce moment là des
obligations dans lesquels on n'a pas
forcément envie d'être en tout cas
serait donc soit on entre en résistance
effectivement et moi j'ai envie de the
lady à certains si certains refusent de
pratiquer ce set cette union ce mariage
qu'il ne le fasse pas mais qu'ils
aillent jusqu'au bout j'en veux dire de
leur opposition et on verra comme
d'autres l'ont fait sur votre chose
pour lesquels il était même en
contradiction vous croire voilà mais je
trouve ça surprenant que la loi puisse
prévoir une évolution tout en anticipant
déjà toutes les dérogations les
exceptions hc bienne en langue française
les exceptions confirment toujours la
règle mais là je trouve qu'en matière
législative
ce serait quand même surprenant donc
voilà je vais simplement précisé mon
propos et je laisse les mêmes questions
que je vais pousser dans la première
intervention bien évidemment oui je
voulais ajouter un mot en tant que
président de la commission des lois
c'est que nous sommes tous attachés à la
loi finalement la loi et notre charte
commune notre règle commune ce qui fonde
dans une république le vivre ensemble et
il m'apparaît vraiment que nous devons
distinguer nos opinions conviction les
oublie nos convictions personnelles que
chacun a le droit d'avoir et le fait que
nous sommes tenus d'appliquer la loi
demain j'aurai l'honneur de présenter un
rapport sur une loi organique pour
mettre en oeuvre un article 11 de la
constitution contre lequel j'ai voté
mais je considère que la constitution
qui a été voté même si je ne vais pas
voter
elle s'applique et qu'elle doit
s'appliquer et je considère que toute
loi nous mettons tous les jours en
oeuvre nous respectons des lois contre
lesquelles nous avons pu voter ou des
lois avec lesquels nous avons marqué un
désaccord mais c'est ce que
j'appellerais le pacte républicain
si bien que même si j'ai bien entendu
j'étais présent ce que le président de
la république a dit lors de la réunion
de l'association des maires de france en
réponse d'ailleurs un monsieur
pélissard j'ai aussi entendu ce qu'il a
dit par la suite il me semble que on
doit respecter cette idée de la loi
alors il est tout à fait clair que les
amendements que vous présentez moi je
j'y suis tout à fait favorable
ils permettent de faire entrer dans les
faits eux le droit tel qu'il est
appliqué et d'autre part il permet en
dernière instance au procureur de la
république de veiller à ce que la loi
s'applique cirque on a le droit vraiment
de combattre une loi un projet de loi
une proposition de loi au parlement nous
le faisons tous finalement si c'est
contraire à notre conviction
une fois que la loi est votée eh bien
nous devons la mettre en oeuvre
même si nous avons marqué tous les
désaccords possible avec cette loi
je crois que c'est le pacte républicain
bon monsieur le président merci monsieur
béland mais vous avez tout dit ou trois
cas vêtements il faut qu'on puisse
conjuguer cette pause 8 et de
délégations verte avec après à la fin
une une obligation de voir le mariage
réalisé dans une mairie dans une mairie
par un élu qui aurait reçu comme c'est
le cas aujourd'hui
dans d'autres cas si une instruction du
procureur
ça n'a pas de deux côtés donc chaud
quand mon sens de voir le procureur
c'est son rôle ils l'assument déjà
veiller à l'application des lois et ses
missions que lui confère précisément la
loi
donc moi monsieur le président je suis
entièrement d'accord et je vous remercie
de votre écoute et de compréhension avec
les positions émises par monsieur
rapporteur a tenus sur les doigts par
vous même en tant que président la
commission des bois donc ce n'est pas
ajouter un mot mais c'est différent avec
le smti karman avec pour le sema c'est
un peu différent
1 c'est vrai que il ya eu donc juste
après le vote de la loi qui était un
petit peu on sent ce
précipité une vague de déférer par les
tribunaux administratifs devraient
trouver un scratch par les préfets après
moi je vais dans le cadre de mon office
de président de l'association des maires
vu le président république
on a vu aussi donc des choses à laquelle
il fallait y remédier on a pu ensuite
voir dans la jurisprudence si je puis
dire de l'état
une distinction entre ce qui était
volonté de ne pas appliquer la loi ou ce
qui était un possibilité d'habiller et
ensuite les chaussons entre hommes
il ya plus de turbulences celui d'hier
c'était déjà un peu différente en
l'espèce puisque de toute façon la loi
doit être appliquée c'est pas on peut
l'appliquer on ne peut pas elle doit
être appliquée il faut que un gardien si
je puis dire
veiller à son application et c'est dans
ses fonctions dans sa nature de ses
responsabilités au procureur
puisqu'on on a ici au nom de l'état
l'état représenté par une nouvelle
injonction
ça me paraît naturel et normal à mon com
suppression sur deux choses d'abord pour
remercier remercier sénat qui a déjà
toiletté si je suis dit elle un stick de
120 dont deux civils
cet article d'ailleurs pas très bien
obligé donc sur les emprunts dont les
époux sous caution ça qu'on porte à la
connaissance des poussins pas normal par
contre qu'on le lise le jour d'une
célébration festive le mariage
fectivement c'était une erreur
le sénat l'a corrigé merci une deuxième
chose sablon et l attention du siona sur
l'aspect purement matérielle c'est que
il va falloir longtemps doute des
mairies de france équipée modifie les
logiciels donc les fabricants les
acteurs producteurs logiciel doit
s'adapter
donc entre la date de promulgation la
loi
et puis la date d'application peut-être
prévoir un des deux mains moi par
exemple pour permettre aux producteurs
logiciel d'être en phase avec la
livraison qu'il nous devons merci oui
monsieur le rapporteur juste un petit
mot pour rappeler à tous nos collègues
que le programme de la république est
chargé de contrôler l'état civil est pas
le préfet
puisque tous les ans nous envoyons
procureur de la république nos registres
de double de nos registres signé de
naissance de des faits de narnia
voilà et c'est lui qui doit même il y
aurait le contrôle est plus fréquemment
on sait très bien qu'on la voit en fin
d'année que bon voilà donc voilà c'est
le procureur public qui peut donner des
instructions et je pense que c'est
évident quand même l'administration
préfectorale
ça me fais pas beaucoup que le viennent
s'immiscer dans une merde voilà
mais bon donc passé une solution moyenne
qui après tout c'est à dire au choix les
préfets avec plaisir vaut mieux le dire
bon ah oui oui oui monsieur monsieur
michel à des déconstructions très très
très fortement racines dans l'histoire
sur le préfet d'apollonia avant est-ce
qu'il ya d'autres paroles il n'y a pas
d'autres d'autres propos pas d'autres
curiosités à satisfaire bien bien qu'oui
madame boulet je peux pas vous laisser
comme ça j'ai le président évidemment la
question que je me posais sait on parle
de dunes d'une vague de combien de
mariage parce que je veux dire que quand
on a l'impression que les trente six
mille six cents communes de france vont
du jour au matin recevoir une espèce de
déferlante de mariage ou de demandes
d'union enfin je sais pas j'ai pas le
sentiment que ce soit le cas en
admettant des résidents secondaires
parisiens viennent se perdre et se
marier dans le perche ornais enfin
j'espère qu'on a une idée
de la statistique de ce que savoura
représenter parce que une espèce de
volant comme ça d'inquiétude mais j'ai
pas quand même pas le sentiment que
notre pays va du jour au lendemain être
inondées par une vague de demandes
d'union pour tous
merci monsieur le président que tant le
sénat qui représente les territoires de
la république on ne considère pas qu'on
se perde ans aucun territoire fussent le
perche
nous sommes beaucoup de respect pour le
perche et donc et non seulement le
perche orne et pour eux il ya aussi un
perche dans l'eure-et-loir et tous les
perches sont dignes de notre respect
mais je ne sais pas si on peut répondre
à votre question sur les prévisions
statistiques
monsieur le rapporteur non on peut
répondre madame boulet vous êtes vous
avez lu les dernières études de l'insee
bon qui donne un total qui estime bon
atome de coupe aujourd'hui homosexuels
etc
admettons que tous veuillent s'est
mariée ce qui n'est sûrement pas le cas
bon il y aura peut-être la première
année un nombre appréciable qu'après ça
iran des croissants voilà comme pour le
pacs dans le pacte soit disant été fait
pour les couples homosexuels
ce qui est faux d'ailleurs si départ il
est terré pour tout le monde et
aujourd'hui on va c'est tout le monde
qui s'en est emparé
donc alors ensuite dans les amendements
qui ont été dans l'amendement qui a été
adopté par l'assemblée
votre premier bon ça permet non je ne
pense pas qu'un couple de même fait
qu'il va se marier veut avoir une
confrontation avec un maire ou sans
trophée municipal d'hier c'est comme ça
serait complètement ridicule donc il
peut quand même peu réfléchir la
question voilà et voir avant où habitent
ses parents
et si ça serait pas plus judicieux
d'aller se marier même à saint tropez
cas
que dans le perche voilà oies grasses
nature voilà donc ce que cache partout
mais donc gros voilà donc je crois que
moi je pense que monsieur moi je le dis
ici public mais tant pis je pense est
une question qui devra être abordé en
fait comment j'aborderai en séance de
façon comment dirais-je minimale pour ne
pas déchaîner des passions de tous côtés
et que les amendements proposés par là
et même le parijs correctement répondre
à la question
voyez que il me semble qu'il y assez
large assentiment monsieur le président
sur les trois amendements que vous avez
proposé avec quelques nuances et et j'ai
bien entendu ce qu'a dit monsieur madame
kutcher manne pour je ne voulais pas
pour le troisième incendie le troisième
amendement dans la catégorie de
l'assentiment mais pour ce qui est des
autres collègues qui se sont exprimés
mais cela paraît tout à fait raisonnable
bon voila si monsieur le président je
voudrais rebondir sur derniers mots
qu'ils utilisent et monsieur le
président raisonnable du moins avant
l'anglais mef sont raisonnables et
responsables
on sait bien que la musique
l'association qui représente tous les
maires de france donc au fourgon il faut
qu'on trouve la voie moyenne qui permet
effectivement de 17 d'où l'impératif
respect de la loi mais aussi respect des
consciences je crois que ces trois
amendements échos qui concoureront
efficacement après avoir reçu cet après
midi monsieur le président de
l'association des maires de france
nous avons l'honneur de recevoir
maintenant monsieur jérôme guedj qui est
comme vous le savez président du conseil
général de l'essonne et qui a été
mandaté en sa qualité de vice-président
de l'association de l'assemblée des
départements de france pour représenter
l'assemblée des départements de france
qui est par ailleurs député puisque vous
voyez qu'il existe
toujours cette pratique anti que du
cumul des mandats et donc qui a fait le
sacrifice des questions d'actualité de
l'assemblée nationale pour venir parler
rossé bas et nous l'en remercions
alors monsieur le président vous savez
que nous sommes très attentifs bien sûr
à ce que pense ici les associations
d'élus puisque il ne vous a pas échappé
que la constitution dit que le sénat
représente les collectivités locales de
la république je vous rassure tout de
suite en vous disant que ça ne veut pas
dire que l'assemblée n'a pas une mission
éminente dans tous les domaines et
notamment pour ce qui concerne des
collectivités locales puisque c'est un
sujet dont vous parlez d'ailleurs
actuellement sur les modes de scrutin
je voulais donc vous souhaiter la
bienvenue si vous le voulez bien nous
pourrions vous donner la parole pour un
exposé liminaire sur la loi sur le
mariage pour tous
et puis je pourrais donner la parole à
nos deux rapporteurs jambières michel
pour la commission des lois
michel meunier pour la commission des
affaires sociales et puis à l'ensemble
de nos collègues
donc si vous venez d'accord de monsieur
le président je vous donne la parole
très bien merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
d'abord vous dire le plaisir qui est le
mien d'être présent aujourd'hui dans
cette maison que j'ai eu bien connu dans
ma jeunesse puisque j ai été l'assistant
parlementaire d'un sénateur devenu
illustre on peut le dire je suis ici
naturellement comme président du conseil
général de l'essonne et qui a quitté le
sénat pour devenir illustre bon alors et
aussi voilà dois le dire ce qui est ben
voilà c'est pas le cas de monsieur de
l'assistant qui depuis
bon je n'aurais pas dû faire cette
remarque mais que voulez vous je ne
résiste pas à la tentation
d'abord vous dire que je suis ici comme
en effet vice président de la commission
des affaires sociales de l'assemblée des
départements de france et à la demande
de claudy lebreton pour que les choses
soient claires et pour la l'honnêteté de
nos débats il faut savoir que
l'assemblée des départements de france
et j'avais fait la même remarque puisque
j'avais été également auditionné par la
commission semblable à l'assemblée
nationale l'assemblée des départements
de france n'a pas pris de position
formelle sur le projet de loi relatif au
mariage et à l'adoption pour les couples
du même sexe n'ont que l'adf se
désintéresse de cette question mais il
n'y a pas eu dans ce dans le
fonctionnement voulu consensuel de l'adf
un espace à une prise de position qui
puisse l'être tout autant
néanmoins et c'est ce sur quoi je vais
centre et mon propos qui sera peut-être
un peu décousu mais en tous les cas qui
cherchera à répondre à celle des
interrogations que vous pouvez vous
poser savoir en quoi ce texte impact le
fonctionnement des conseils généraux et
en quoi
il est porteur d'un certain nombre
d'évolutions de droit et de fait comme
vous le savez c'est principalement sur
le volet de l'adoption compétences
reconnues aux conseils généraux que nous
allons être questionné la dimension
mariage droit civil pratique du mariage
incombant d'avantagé vous avez j'imagine
évoqué tout à l'heure avec le président
de l'association des maires des maires
de france sur le volet de l'adoption
d'abord voir d'où nous partons mais je
veux pas vraiment insister sur des
points que vous maîtrisez parfaitement
les uns et les autres
les conseils généraux sont chargés de la
délivrance de l'agrément pour les
requérants au titre de l'adoption qu'il
s'agisse de l'adoption pour un pupille
de l'état d'un enfant confié à un
organisme autorisé pour l'adoption ou
d'un enfant étranger
la délivrance de l'agrément répond un
processus là aussi que vous que vous
connaissez et la loi telle qu'elle est
envisagée permettra à des personnes de
même sexe de former une demande
d'adoption dans les conditions
comparables à couples hétérosexuels qui
aujourd'hui formulent des demandes
d'adoption donc il n'ya pas de
dispositif spécifique relatif à
l'adoption pour les personnes de même
sexe c'est le premier point qu'il faut
souligner qui de toute façon est une
évidence s'agissant d'une loi dont le
fil à plomb le fil rouge la matrice est
celle de l'égalité par conséquent
n'avait pas inventé un dispositif
spécifique donc partant de ce constat il
ya du point de vue des conseils généraux
il n'y a pas de commentaire particulier
à faire nous continuerons à instruire à
instruire les demandes d'agrément formé
par ces couples selon les critères de
droit commun qui sont posées par
l'article
225-81 code de l'action sociale et des
familles avec comme l'a aussi fil rouge
comme principe directeur s'assurer c'est
la mission des services du conseil
général
et c'est là l'élément qui est pris en
compte au moment de la délivrance de
l'agrément d'une seule chose à savoir
est ce que les conditions d'accueil
offertes par le demandeur sur le plan
familial éducatif et psychologique
correspondent aux besoins et à l'intérêt
de l'enfant adoptée c'est dans ce cadre
là comme pour les demandes formulées par
les personnes va parler par les couples
hétérosexuels
leleu l'appréciation de la délivrance de
l'agrément ne pourra se faire que sur
l'évaluation des conditions psychosocial
affectives et éducatives fourni fournies
par le couple alors pour autant depuis
des années les conseils généraux c'est
le petit remarque que je veux faire à
cet instant ne sont pas totalement
déconnectée de la problématique de
l'enjeu de société de l'adoption par des
personnes vivant en couple homosexuel
puisque comme vous le savez depuis une
réforme législative de 1966 est ouverte
dans le droit français la faculté à
l'adoption pour une personne seule et
cette faculté de fait est utilisé par
des personnes homosexuelles vivant
vivant en couple
la seule particularité et là vous me
permettrez de matinée mon propos
d'expériences personnelles de celle de
président de conseil général
la seule particularité c'est que ils
étaient constatés ces dernières années
que la situation de couple de la
personne faisant une demande seul était
pas forcément mise en avant dans la
demande
à ce moment là on peut on pourra revenir
dans les changes sur les raisons pour
lesquelles cette situation n'était pas
mise en avant mais de fait les services
dès que le service adoption des conseils
généraux ont une pratique ancienne de
couples homosexuels dont il devine dont
il 28 l'existence mais qui ne sont pas
formellement présent le plus souvent
dans le dossier deuxième élément qui
fait que mais je reviendrai sur celui ci
qui fait que les conseils généraux sont
été interpellé sur la question de
l'adoption par des personnes
homosexuelles
c'est quand le droit s'est penché sur ce
sujet la jurisprudence célèbre celle de
la cour européenne des droits de l'homme
2 janvier 2008 qui mettait en cause
conseil général dont j'aurai la pudeur
de taire le nom que je crois que c'est
le jura voilà donc je ne le fais pas non
mais c'est parce que je n'étais pas sûr
de me rappeler je voulais pas confondre
le jura et les vosges mais j'irai peu
importe sa eu le mérite de poser une
jurisprudence
c'est à dire que là haut non du principe
de non-discrimination principe
supérieure en droit européen et forte
heureusement aussi existe en droit en
droit français
mais il est clairement établi qu'il ne
peut pas y avoir de refus d'agrément de
revues de refus de délivrance de
l'agrément motivés par l'orientation
sexuelle du couple parce que le conseil
général du jura je crois en tous les cas
avec lui d'une certaine manière la
franchise ou la bêtise à penser comme on
veut de motiver son refus d'agrément par
cette raison on a au moins la clarté de
cette jurisprudence qui dit
l'orientation sexuelle ne saurait
constituer un motif discriminatoire de
refus d'agrément et depuis cette
jurisprudence
mais c'était déjà le cas avant les
conseils généraux se sont questionnés
sur leurs pratiques en tous les cas pour
s'assurer que il n'ya pas c'est une fin
de non recevoir sur des personnes seules
demandant l'adoption une fin de non
recevoir dès l'instant où l'orientation
sexuelle en fin de non-recevoir franche
ou insidieuse la discrimination peut
être direct je vous refuse l'adoption
parce que vous nous dites que vous êtes
en situation de couple homosexuel elle
peut être indirecte ou ou contournée en
invoquant des par des subterfuges et par
des formules alambiquées
le fait que l'environnement familial ne
fournit pas les conditions
d'épanouissement et d'intérêts et
d'intérêt de l'enfant juste je m'arrête
un instant sur ce point c'est vrai que
depuis cette jurisprudence
beaucoup de conseils généraux se sont
emparés du sujet pour s'assurer que les
pratiques de leurs agents et et
respectueuse de ce principe de non
discrimination et tout est aussi pour
s'assurer que en dans l'examen d'une
demande par une personne seule et bien
on faisait abstraction de l'orientation
sexuelle ce qui aboutit et là je livre
mon expérience personnelle à cette
situation comme moi j'ai qualifiée
d'hypocrite et de bancal qui consistait
à ce que je l'évoquais à l'instant des
personnes soient dans le déni de ce qu
est un élément fondateur de l'orientis
de leur identité
l'orientation sexuelle est un élément de
l'identité et cette identité les
probablement importante pour apprécier
les capacités psychologiques affectives
et éducatives de la personne et donc
dans ce grand moment de vérité qui doit
être la procédure de l'adoption et de
l'agrément d'une certaine manière
directement ou indirectement ont invité
ces personnes seules à nier une partie
de la réalité est presque à mentir c'est
la raison pour laquelle de manière
parfois un peu affirmée et revendicative
c'est mon cas on a délivré certains
conseils généraux ont délivrer des
agréments moi je les fais en juillet
enfin au conseil général de l'essonne
dans un dossier dans lequel très
clairement la requérante qui demandait à
adopter seul avait d'emblée affiché est
presque revendiquer sa dimension de
de vie en couple homosexuel et donc
l'appréciation faite par les services du
conseil général a dit ok nous apprécions
la capacité de la requérante tout seul
mais non déconnecté de son environnement
de la personne avec laquelle elle vit et
l'ailleurs personnes avec d'ailleurs
avec laquelle elle vivait avait elle
même un enfant issu d'une vie antérieure
et tous ces énormes et de mandat devait
être pris en compte dès l'instant où
l'intérêt de l'enfant s'apprécient je
cite toujours ces trois éléments sur le
plan familial éducatif et psychologique
voilà c'est vrai qu'on était confronté à
ses côtés un petit peu hypocrite je le
dis tout de suite en reconnaissant le
mariage pour ces couples
on va enfin sortir de cette forme
d'hypocrisie on appréciera le couple
dans sa globalité puisque le couple sera
celui qui aura la double capacité qui
adoptera conjointement et non pas et non
pas séparément
voilà je veux juste terminer je vous ai
parlé de la démarche qui avait été celle
que j'avais prises moi comme président
de conseil général de l'essonne à
travers la reconnaissance de en tous les
cas la délivrance cet agrément en
connaissance de cause
c'est vrai d'autres départements
d'autres départements l'avait fait nous
on avait fait 10 compris de manière un
petit peu tonitruante
je le revendique parce que ça avait une
dimension aussi de deux débats publics
en prolongement de ceux ci moi j'ai
saisi l'assemblée des départements de
france de cette question
individuellement tous les cas chacun des
présidents de conseils généraux en leur
proposant une charte de l'adoption sans
discrimination qui était la reprise je
dirais des principes posés par le droit
et surtout la nécessité pour les
conseils généraux et pour nos services
d'échangé justement sur les pratiques et
les bonnes pratiques
ce qui a débouché sur l'organisation
d'un colloque national à evry en avril
2012 sur et c'était le premier colloque
de ce type adoption et homoparentalité
centrée sur les conseils généraux mais
invitant beaucoup d acteurs de ce débat
juriste pédopsychiatre cliniciens
sociologues anthropologues
les actes de ce colloque chez le
président peuvent être être consultés
sur le site internet dont on vous
donnera les coordonnées et je vous ai
amené jean n'est qu'un seul don pourra
naturellement vous en fournir d'autre
les actes de ce colloque qui donne y
compris le point de vue de plusieurs
conseils généraux notamment des
témoignages intéressants du service
adoption de la ville de ha du conseil
général de paris sur les pratiques en
l'espèce
beaucoup de ceux qui sont intervenus
dans ce premier colloque sur l'adoption
et homoparentalité sont ce que votre
commission va auditionner comme la
commission à l'international avait avait
auditionné mais c'était pour nous aussi
une manière de donner à voir et de poser
le débat sur la place publique
enfin et ce sera vraiment mon dernier
mot l'avantagent de ce que vous avez
appelé le cumul
monsieur le président qui chez moi je
tiens à le dire est un cumul temporaire
je ne suis que le suppléant d'un d'un
ministre auquel je souhaite pleine
réussite dans une réussite et longue
longue vie dans son mandat ministériel
mais donc ça m'a fourni quand même
l'avantagé de pouvoir participer et
assister au sang neuf heures de débat à
l'assemblée à l'assemblée nationale je
sais pas si ça peut éclairer le sénat je
sors un instant de ma casquette de
président de conseil général
vous vous dire que dans les débats
pourtant l'on que nous avons connu à
l'assemblée nationale tout ce qu'on
vient d'évoquer sur la procédure
d'adoption le rôle par les conseils
généraux a somme toute été un sujet très
marginalement abordés y compris dans sa
dimension pratique si ce n'est sur une
question mais à laquelle nous ne sommes
pas capables de répondre
est-ce que l'introduction de cette loi
va avoir un impact
est-ce que ça va avoir un accroissement
des demandes
d'adoption d'agrément par les les
les pour les conseils généraux
je crois qu'il faut raison garder pour
deux raisons la première c'est qu'on est
bien conscient que la loi par le mariage
va surtout permettre de légaliser si
j'ose dire et va se traduire par des
adoptions intrafamiliales sur des
situations de drop de fait qui sont déjà
qu'ils sont déjà présentes et que
s'agissant de la délivrance d'agrément
en vue d'une adoption et notamment d'une
adoption à l'international les personnes
homosexuelles sont elles mêmes
consciente et lucide que malheureusement
de nombreux pays acp dans l'adoption à
l'international oppose là pour le coup
très clairement c'est des choses qu'on
est évoquée d'ailleurs vous y trouverez
des passages très intéressant dans notre
dans notre colloque oppose une fin de
non recevoir tout de suite à des
agréments délivrés par des personnes par
les personnes au moment dé livrer à des
personnes homosexuelles
on connaît des pays peut s'agir de
l'ukraine il peut s'agir de la chine je
crois il peut s'agir d' haïti pour
lesquels soit de droit soit dans la
pratique dans une forme de jurisprudence
orale sont extrêmement réticents et donc
c'est pas ça non plus qui va créer un
appel d'air en tous les cas dans l'étude
d'impact y compris dans les estimations
qu'on pourrait faire dans les conseils
généraux
c'est pas ça qui va créer une
déstabilisation de l' équilibre
financier des conseils généraux qui par
ailleurs connaît bien d'autres
difficultés mais ce n'est pas le sujet
du jour voilà je vous remercie
merci monsieur le président que jérôme
guedj pour toute votre toutou votre
rapport sur ce sujet important et
auxquels je pense le sénat va
s'intéresser c'est pas du tout une
question marginale par rapport au texte
c'est un sujet important quand je donne
tout de suite la parole à jean pierre
michel rapporteur de la commission des
lois mais merci moi je n'ai pas de
questions posées à jérôme gay parce que
je partage totalement ce qu'il dit par
contre je vais les aider par un peu tout
et michel meunier rapporteur pour avis
qui est
le plus à même que moi de peut-être
d'interroger c'est la prime d'adoption
alors madame magnétique passée j'ai
remarqué que c'était un très bon couple
alors allez-y bas d'allemagne et
résidents donc moi j'ai eu l'honneur
pendant presque huit ans d'être vice
présidente département de loire
atlantique sur la protection de
l'enfance présidente du conseil de
famille de loire-atlantique et donc je
signais comme vous et comme plusieurs
collègues peut-être ici les désagréments
aux candidats à l'adoption
vous avez dit l'essentiel c'est vrai
qu'il y avait pas mal d'hypocrisie
disons que lorsque l'on à gré un
candidats célibataires hommes femmes ont
peu importe la façon dont cet effet on
se doutait parfois qu'il y avait
sûrement de la souffrance ou en tout cas
une partie fin vous l'avez très bien dit
elle de la personne en elle-même
intrinsèque qui était masqué dissimulé
voilà mais ceci dit l'agrément de ne pas
l'enfant vous l'avez vous dis aussi et
que l'adoption à l'international de plus
en plus se transforme et peut-être aussi
va sûrement de pâtir d'une certaine
manière une certaine suspicion on le
voit du côté de la russie des biens sur
les demandes de célibataire ou de
couples de même sexe
moi je pense un peu comme vous l'avez
dit que la question de l'adoption sera
sûrement plus tôt du point de vue de
l'adoption de l'enfant du conjoint
avec qui et quelle on se mariera
l'adoption conjointe se réalisera
certainement de manière sûrement plus
affirmée et plus ouverte mais encore une
fois si rien ne se passe elle ne sera
hélas pas forcément possible dans la
réalité un intérêt quand même dans ce
débat sur le mariage ou même si ce sujet
de l'adoption ou ne sera pas mise en
avant est un premier élément en face à
une première importance on voit bien
l'importance d'avoir à des bassins
complet sur les questions d'adoption
parce que on entends je vais vous le
dire énormément de contrevérités de
choses fausses ou et sur l'adoption
l'adoption plénière
l'accès aux origines on pense que c'est
impossible
or pour avoir présidé l conseil de
famille on voit bien que lorsque une
femme accouche enfance en france sous
secret elle a la possibilité de donner
sur l'identité sous pli fermé et que
l'enfant après 18 ans aura la faculté et
le droit de voilà de d'ouvrir cette
enveloppe est enfant il pourra le faire
avant ses 18 ans en étant accompagné de
ses parents
voilà on met tout ça je pense qu'on en
parlera ailleurs plus tard dans un autre
cadre de projets toi
tim alain meunier e s que vous voulez
répondre tout de suite monsieur zhu deux
rapporteurs peut-être vous préférez peut
être qu'on demande les autres questions
intervention qui veut qui va intervenir
oui alors j'ai madame benbassa après
monsieur lecerf il n'y a pas d'autres
interventions dont madame pour le moment
madame benbassa merci monsieur gates
pour votre exposé très complet et vous
avez également fait allusion au fait que
dans les pays où ces coûts qui vont
chercher l'enfant il n'y a pas on peut
pas les on peut pas les obliger à l'or
jaune et la possibilité d'adopter ça ça
ne relève plus de notre compétence
mais alors à ce moment-là c'est
l'agrément
ça ne signifie rien on sait qu'il ya
très peu d'enfants français qui peuvent
être données en âge d'adoption il ya des
enfants d'un âge plus élevé je sais pas
si les couples level nîmes est ce qu'il
n'est pas possible de passer des accords
danse dans ce sens
est ce qu'il ya des possibilités de
droit international et de dans les
accords dauphins ou mettent des codie si
enfin de faire quelque chose afin que
ces adoptions piste est en partie
satisfaite
voilà ma question merci alors monsieur
le cerf mais monsieur le président oui
je je je souhaite qu'on soit très
attentifs au fait que l'adoption par des
couples de même sexe n'entraîne pas des
conséquences dommageables sur l'adoption
par des personnes célibataires
car il ya effectivement toute une série
de personnes célibataires qui souhaitent
adopter qui quelquefois d'ailleurs vive
et où auparavant couples qui ont eu un
projet effectivement familial qui n'a
pas abouti qui ont recouru dans le cas
de la loi à la procréation médicale
assistée sans que ça réussisse également
le couple s'était filocher en quelque
sorte est l'un des deux souhaite
effectivement poursuivre le projet
d'adoption ce que je
très bien donc ma crainte c'est un peu
si vous voulez le risque de conséquences
dommageables de l'adoption par les
couples homosexuels sur les personnes
célibataires et c'est aussi le fait que
d'après les chiffres que que j'ai vu
mais j'ai été incapable de les vérifier
le nombre d'adoptions par les femmes
célibataires déjà pas très important
mais lors le nombre d'adoptions par les
hommes célibataires et totalement
dérisoire ce qui m'interpelle également
sur les raisons pour lesquelles on a
effectivement d'aider des chiffres de ce
type
at il d'autres remarques madame boulet
je vais vous poser une question galère
stupide mais lorsque vous avez des
présomptions lourde et concordants de ce
que l'adoption est demandée par un
couple homosexuel est ce que vous vous
le notez dans le dans le dossier est ce
que vous vous avez une indication dans
le dossier où est-ce que ça reste votre
intuition parce que c'est relativement
important pour le pour le suivi quand la
loi sera votée ce sera autre chose mais
pour l'instant elle n'est pas donc est
ce que est ce que vous mettez une
mention dans le dossier moi je suis
toujours un peu inquiète des mentions
des fichiers des suivis donc simplement
puisque vous avez indiqué que vous aviez
à gré à ce type d'adoption eux de façon
ouverte et explicite est ce qu est ce
que vous vous en fait mention dans le
dossier
quand encore d'autres questions donc il
y en a pas donc je vous rends la parole
monsieur gouache pour répondre aux deux
rapporteurs et aux trois intervenants ou
trois intervenants alors là aussi de
manière de manière un petit peu décousu
ce qui est certain c'est que puisqu'on
parle d'adoption
à l'occasion de cette loi sur le mariage
et l'adoption pour les couples de même
sexe
et là je vous rejoins totalement ça nous
invite à questionner l'adoption dans ce
pays je crois que ce serait une erreur
et c'est d'ailleurs une des vertus de ce
texte sur le mariage et l'adoption pour
les couples de même sexe c'est qu'il a
une vertu un peu messianique d'une
certaine manière c'est quand en parlant
du dés couples homosexuels et bien et en
s'interrogeant sur les questions
d'égalité
on va questionner bien des sujets on
pourrait parler de la pma qui est pas le
sujet du jour mais on a parlé de la pma
et de fait on questionne sur l'ensemble
de la pma d'ailleurs pour l'ensemble des
couples sûr de la manière qu'on on a des
discussions qui ont été vives dans le
débat parlementaire sur les éléments
relatifs au statut des tiers
le co par an le beau parent etc
s'agissant de l'adoption c'est
incontestablement un sujet qui doit être
mis sur la table le dispositif je le dis
actuel n'est pas satisfaisant a plu à
plus d'un titre
et moi je fais partie de ceux qui sont
se réjouissent de l'annoncé d'une loi à
venir sur la famille dans laquelle moi
je souhaite je ne sais pas si ce sera le
cas qu'on puisse avoir une réflexion sur
l'adoption
qu'il s'agisse de l'adoption
internationale en étant quand même
conscient de des chiffres très
préoccupant ont constaté ces dernières
années les chiffres ont été publiés la
semaine dernière
on est quasiment sûr une division par
deux des chiffres d'il ya quatre ans on
est à moins de à 1500 et 1700 enfants
effectivement adoptés on a connu jusqu'à
4000 enfants adoptés à l'international
aujourd'hui c'est extrêmement
préoccupant donc est ce que la procédure
est ce que les mécanismes est ce que les
conventions à ce que les partenariats ça
pourrait prendre un petit peu madame
benbassa peuvent se nouer avec eux les
états deuxième élément lille sur la
pratique de l'adoption qui répond à une
des questions qui a été évoquée qui est
est ce que en ouvrant l'adoption à une
nouvelle catégorie de population on va
pas épuisé le vivier dans une sorte de
compétition de concurrence ça c'est pour
le coup je l' ai entendu dans le débat
parlementaire parfois je suis au sénat
dont j'avais raison garder mais parfois
avec avec quelques extraits toujours
raison quand même assemblée nationale
alors allez-y avec parfois quelques
excès ou en tous les cas quelques
arguments non je le dis ils m'ont
parfois laissé pantois sur le thème on
va ouvrir l'adoption aux couples de même
sexe donc ça va assécher le vivez de le
vivier de l'adoption pour les autres
couples que ce soit à l'international ou
ou pour les pupilles ou pour les
pupilles 2
de l'état y compris alors avec des
arguments encore plus un peu hallucinant
qui consistait à dire dans ce cas là il
faut pouvoir donner à des parents qui
craindraient de mourir qui pourraient
craindre de mourir d'interdire que leurs
enfants ne soient adoptés ultérieurement
par des couples homosexuels enfin je
sais pas si de tels amendements qui sont
envisagées au sénat mais ça va donner
lieu à des discussions un peu
surréaliste en tous les cas c'était le
cas pour nous à l'assemblée nationale je
ne crois pas qu'il puisse y avoir une
concurrence en revanche que pour les
raisons qui ont été évoqués l'essentiel
de l'adoption va se faire de l'adoption
du de l'enfant du conjoint
ça va être une adoption intrafamiliales
de régularisation si je veux dire est qu
après s'agissant du flux il sera limité
pour autant et c'est là que la réflexion
sur l'adoption globale doit être posée
je pense qu'on a un problème dans notre
pays
s'agissant de l'adoption plénière ou
simple des enfants confiés à l'aide
sociale à l'enfance au conseil au
président du conseil général
on a aujourd'hui un peu moins de 2500
enfants qui ont le statut de pupille de
l'état est de fait très peu en tous les
cas pas suffisamment ne sont proposés à
l'adoption pour aujourd'hui pour des
couples homosexuels
soit parce que les fameux besoins
spécifiques liés à leur âge alors
fratrie à leur situation de handicap
fait qu' ils ne sont pas j'aime passer
terme intéressant en tous les cas il n'y
a pas eu ma demande mais il ya aussi je
le dis mais je fais un pas de côté par
rapport au terme de l'audition mais
aussi parce qu'il ya une cuve d'une
tradition française très forte du
maintien du lien biologique avec les
parents rendre adoptables un enfant
pupille de l'état c'est au terme d'un
processus qui fait que ben ça prend du
temps ça prend des années que le concert
par exemple de délaissement parental et
très peu reconnue en france par rapport
à une conception anglo-saxonne qui
permet quand même
donc voilà je pense que ça vaut le coup
d'avoir cette réflexion pour se dire
qu'il ya des enfants confiés à l'aide
sociale à l'enfance qui peuvent être
peut-être plus facilement adaptable pour
les couples à venir alors sur les deux
questions
pardon sur la question précise de la le
commande je cherche le terme de la de
savoir si on reconnaît ainsi on indique
l'orientation sexuelle savez l'adoption
c'est un processus itératif c'est pas
une instruction administrative classique
il ya une sorte de colloques singuliers
de de confiance qui s'établit entre
l'autorité administrative les services
du conseil général mais qui sont
travailleurs sociaux médecins
psychologues en fonction de l'équipe et
qui peut être pluridisciplinaire et donc
il ya une sorte de va et vient une
discussion quand dans le cas le plus
simple que celui que j'ai mentionné
juillet 2011 au conseil général de
l'essonne figure donc dans la délivrance
de l'agrément est un acte motivé la
situation de couple
d'ailleurs moi j'ai rencontré les deux
intéressés après la délivrance de cet
agrément pas ce que je souhaitais quand
même incarner incarner les choses elles
sont bien conscients d'une chose
elles ont franchi quelque chose qui pour
elles en terme d'identité et de symboles
étaient importantes
elle ya une demande par une personne
seule puisque la loi n'était pas encore
que virtuelle à l'époque on étions qu'en
mai 2011 ou en juillet 2011 mais c'était
important pour elle que celle qui a
adopté des deux dans le couple qui elle
était détentrice de la demande était la
requérante affirme dansant dans sa
demande dans son instruction qu'elle
était en couple avec quelqu'un qu'une
histoire d'amour exister qu'une famille
existait déjà puisque je voulais dit
tout à l'heure
la conjointe est elle même maman d'un
grand enfant
donc là de fait et sa figure dans la
motivation de l'agrément et en même
temps consciente de ça elles disent
notre parcours du combattant ne fait que
continuer parce qu'à l'international
elles veulent adopter à l'étranger
elles savent que le fait d'avoir été
dans cette sincérité de leur histoire
personnelle allait constituer un
obstacle plus grand que si elle avait
fait comme la plupart vous l'avez évoqué
tout à l'heure était dans le déni
voilà c'est une personne seule donc le
plus souvent dans les personnes seules
n'y a pas cette mention sauf sauf à la
demande expresse encore une fois on ne
peut pas imposer ça
est ce que il y aurait presque quelque
chose d'assez terrible qui serait pour
une personne seule
on doit presque faire abstraction ce
aussi incroyable de l'orientation
sexuelle de la personne mentionnée dans
la motivation l'orientation sexuelle et
avoue aboutir à un refus ça peut donc
aboutir à une suspicion que c'est ça qui
a motivé le refus est en sens inverse
faudrait pas qu'à une discrimination
positive qui aboutissent qui aboutissent
à cela donc vraiment pour dire que le
système actuel était bancale alors les
chiffres ont été demandés c'est moins de
10% des demandes d'agrément qui sont le
fruit de personnes seules et parmi elles
c'est inférieur à 1% enfin c'est même
moins s'agissant donc la plupart des cas
ce sont des femmes pendant la 99,5 % ce
sont sont des femmes les chiffres sont
approximatifs n'est pas de consolidation
nationale
à ma connaissance mais bon l'expérience
croiser ce que j'ai entendu dans les
différents moments
alors après se sont très peu d'hommes
après ça renvoie pourquoi très peu
d'hommes je veux dire très franchement
parce qu on est encore dans un modèle
qui considère que dans la procédure
d'agrément l'évaluation des capacités
familial éducatif et psychologique
suppose encore la présence d'au moins
une femme dans le dans le couple voilà
que cet élément là qu est un élément de
pratique qui est un élément de huy de
pratique professionnelle
il est susceptible aussi d'évoluer au
gré de l'évolution de la législation
voilà sur sur la question de madame la
sénatrice benbassa sur sur les accords
internationaux fin je ne suis pas le
plus expert en la matière al'inverse il
ya des pays qui ne manifestent pas de
d'obstacles à l'international je crois
qu'on peut citer l'afrique du sud par
exemple l'afrique du sud considère qu'
il de passer ça ne pose pas de problème
si la personne arrive avec un agrément
dans lequel il est fait mention de la
nature homosexuelle du couple dans
lequel l'enfant serait
orienté merci alors merci pour ces
réponses j'ai deux nouvelles séries
d'inscription donc madame qu kerman qui
veut s'inscrire encore personne madame
cukierman très vite le temps madame
kuperman aube alors pas vite de de re2
question de remarques sur les propos qui
viennent d'être tenu bon - je crois
effectivement que sur la question de
l'adoption va s'ouvrir après l'adoption
de ce texte de véritables débats et il
va falloir qu'on nous interrogions
effectivement collectivement sur ce que
doit être est ce qu est l adoption
je crois que ce que vous disiez sur la
réalité à l'international est le dilemme
finalement qui est posé un certain
nombre de coupes c'est à dire de dire la
vérité de ce qu'ils sont quitte à se
voir fermer les portes de l'adoption
internationale on l'a vu notamment sur
le cas de l'espagne à partir au moment
où l'espagne a légiféré le mariage pour
les personnes de même sexe pour
l'ensemble des coupes des couples pardon
l'espagnol à l'adoption internationale
sai dans un certain nombre de pays
complexifier au mas dieu donc ça je
crois que c'est une réalité il faudra
effectivement pour qu'on puisse avoir
cette réflexion
moi j'avais une question à poser
peut-être plus directement au président
de conseil général que vous êtes et puis
qui avait suivi ces questions là sur la
question de l'agrément
je crois je suis je met nullement doute
la qualité et la capacité de travail des
différents fonctionnaires qui sont
amenés à donner l'agrément
vous avez évoqué la difficulté quand
même quand il n'ya pas de personnages
féminins on va dire
donc de futures mères à avoir l'agrément
comment est-ce que les conseils généraux
travail je sais pas sensibilise évite le
fait qu'à un moment donné finalement
vous ne voyez que les robes que les
demandes
une fois les enquêtes réalisées ou des
recours d'individus si vraiment il y as
mais on sait bien quelles que soient la
nature d'ailleurs du couple
souvent quand il y à des refus voilà
l'effondrement est tel pour le coûteux
qu'on n'est pas dans la démarche
forcément aller vers un repos je sais
pas si c'est peut-être pas très clair
mais vraiment au sein du conseil général
comment est ce que vous faites pour que
cet acte qui est un acte humain de faire
l'enquêté donner l'agrément et bien soit
le plus objectif possible et donc est ce
que voilà ce que ça passe par les
sensibilisations est-ce que l'adoption
de la loi va vous amener au sein des
différents conseils généraux et donc
l'association des départements de france
y est certainement réfléchi à mettre en
place un certain nombre d'actions pour
pour travailler et éviter en tout cas
que ce que la loi permette d'un côté ne
filtre du principe de réalité main sur
territoire de le rattraper
voilà
si madame que kirmann damoclès oui merci
de ce président c'est une question qui
va dans le prolongement de celle de ma
collègue qui est sur l'autre côté de la
pente
al'inverse on sait bien il ya des
familles qui ne donne signe à leurs
enfants fils ou fille que via une carte
postale parents etc puisque c'est le
minimum légal pour que l'enfant ne soit
pas adoptables
comment peut-on humainement là encore
considéré qu'il s'agit là d'un signe
suffisant pour que l'enfant ne soit pas
adoptée mais ce qu'ils appellent la
aussi quelque chose à revoir
or monsieur gournac vous m'excusez jeu
je m'inscris et bien tardivement c'est
pas grave voudrais confirmer que je
viens d'entendre j'étais vice-président
du conseil général chargé des affaires
sociales de mon département et je dois
dire que devant les instructions des
psychologues des personnes qui reçoivent
le couple qui a 50 % de personnes car
pas de casser je vais bien qu'assez
c'est pas nous c'est même pas parce
qu'ils ont entendu non mais c'est de la
façon dont on instruit et je prends le
maire jean-paul de l'essonne et les
yvelines
c'est de la façon dont on instruit et
les questions qu'ils ont posées pourquoi
vous bien avoir un enfant vous et vous
il ya aussi certainement je crois à
faire évoluer cette chose là pour que
pour que par les jantes soldes sont pas
blessés avant même le fait qu'on leur
dise non moi j'ai rencontré et encore
qui travaille pour ma ville d'ailleurs
couple ça marche mais ils ont été
complètement démoralisé la famille les
tenir à la sortie des différents
contacts qu'ils ont eus avec le conseil
général
il a fallu que j'ai les reçoivent j'ai
dû le recevoir trois ou quatre fois
parce qu'ils étaient morts cassez alors
voilà beaucoup d'expressions 1 je
redonne la parole à monsieur guedj pour
répondre aux différents collègues qui
sont intervenus l'échangé pardon
l'échangé et passionnant comme comme à
chaque fois il voyait bien ça confirme
ce qu'on évoquait à savoir quand on
glisse sur le sujet de l'adoption qui
lui intéresse il ya vingt-cinq mille
personnes en france où un peu plus
qu'ils sont détentrices un agrément
d'adoption il y en a entre 5500 6500 par
an donc le flux
augmentent eux deux de 6000 et donc il
ya des vraies questions / / / /
l'adoption alors vous poser une question
sur le sur les sur la manière
je vais commencer par celle là plutôt de
traiter la manière dont dans les équipes
agissent c'est tout l'enjeu de la
formation et des bonnes pratiques
c'est vrai qu'il ya des traditions
professionnel qui existe à certains
endroits alors le hasard j'allais
presque prendre cet exemple là celui des
yvelines qui est un peu connu dans le
monde de l'adoption et je suis
voilà alors j'ai dû moi je me suis
toujours posé la question de savoir si
c'était une une directive politique ou
une pratique professionnelle mais il est
notoire fin je fait offense à personne
nous en parle c'est un département dans
lequel il ya je crois savoir mais je
veux pas donner crédit à des à des
on-dit et lors d'une exigence plus
grande que les couples soient mariés
plutôt que la faculté est offerte par la
loi
bon donc il ya des pratiques qui sont
divergentes d'un endroit à l'autre
l'enjeu c'est peut-être d'éviter de trop
grandes disparités
mais c'est vrai que vous avez utilisé le
terme les personnes sont cassés on
touche à l'intimé cirque questionne d un
des individus
un couple qui est porteur d'un désir
d'un projet familial d'un projet
d'accompagnement d'un enfant et on
l'interrogent dans une sorte de 2,2 ce
qui est parfois vécu et ce qui est
injuste de savoir est-ce que vous avez
une capacité des parents enfin c'est une
question qui est forcément vécu avec
avec 100 de manière très sensible
voilà il ya un enjeu de bonnes pratiques
il ya un enjeu des changes est un enjeu
de pratique professionnelle
moi je souhaite qu'elle puisse être un
peu boosté à l'occasion de cette
réflexion s'agissant de l'orientation
sexuelle
nous on a commencé à le faire c'est un
petit peu le c'est un petit et un petit
peu l'esprit de on avait une quarantaine
de départements qui étaient présents
quand on a organisé ce canton a organisé
ce colloque
on a construit derrière un réseau de 2
dans les différents services service
adoption pour pouvoir au pouvoir
échanger sur la question dieu du
délaissement parental ou en tous les cas
de c'est ce que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure
tiens je pense qu'il faut qu'on ait un
saut législatif ou en tous les cas de
pratiques qui consistent à peut-être est
là c'est mon sentiment personnel être
moins cramponner à une vision très
biologique
dès qu'il ya le maintien d'un lien
biologique avec les parents alors on se
dit que c'est pas possible on d'abord on
oublie que l'adoption simple est
possible à l'adoption simple qui
autorise à ce qu'un enfant et plusieurs
enfants
plusieurs parents reconnue donc jusqu'à
4 cette faculté existe et même cela de
sur l'adoption plénière
je pense qu'il faut qu'on fasse bouger
là aussi l'état du droit en considérant
qu'on peut peut-être constaté le
délaissement parental plus rapidement
que ce n'est le cas aujourd'hui
d'autres remarques d'un meunier
rajoutez peut-être ce qui vient d'être
dit en réponse à ce questionnement
madame pekerman moi je pense que plus le
politique s'en mêlera et mieux ce sera
dire que je fais bien sûr confiance aux
équipes unités d'adoption dans chaque
département mais il faut pas penser ça
comme quelque chose de technique ou de
très spécialisés mais que le politique a
qu'un grand pont ne s'agit évidemment
pas de faire des interventions mais ce
que je veux dire c'est que quelque part
ça rassure aussi et puis ça donne
surtout de l'essence j'ai vraiment je
veux mentionner ce mot paquet
d'ambiguïté dans mes propos on a des
équipes les services adoption dans les
conseils généraux sont des services
importants parce qu'ils sont vraiment
dans 32 dans un sujet pas d'ailleurs
l'aide sociale à l'enfance oralement des
services les plus exigeants dans un comm
service public comme mission parce qu'on
est à chaque fois vraiment sur la crête
dans l'intimé en même temps avec et
c'est vrai que c'est je le confirme donc
cesser ses agences et ses professionnels
ont besoin d'un cadre politique en tous
les cas on les cadre d'orientation de
plus en plus ce n'est pas une obligation
je le dis mais de plus en plus de
conseils généraux à l'occasion de
l'adoption de leur schéma départemental
de l'enfance qui jusque là était très
focalisée justement sur les pratiques de
la zone le placement et ses draps ont
évolué de plus en plus adoption un
questionnement sur calais notre
politique nos orientations en matière
d'adoption ma part dans ce que je vous
ai évoqué sur la non discrimination à
raison de l'orientation sexuelle
c'est une disposition nous avions
intégré dans un schéma de l'enfance au
conseil général de l'essonne dès 2009
et c'est vrai qu'à l'époque il ya pas
beaucoup d pas beaucoup de conseils
généraux qui se posait la question de
savoir quel est notre politique en
matière d'adoption et ça se construit
naturellement avec les services qui ont
besoin on a souvent des équipes qui sont
les équipes stable ancienne donc où se
construit je dirais une pratique à
l'échelle d'un département est le même
vous dire c'est marginal c'est
anecdotique mais on connaît certaines
familles qui sont d'une stratégie je
dirais de localisation d'un département
à l'autre en fonction de ce qu'ils
savent être ça et maintenant les forums
sur internet
on se raconte les choses de ce qu'ils
savent être les pratiques des uns et des
autres et c'est vrai qu'il ya des
endroits qui sont réputées plus dur plus
exigeants que d'autres voilà donc je
crois que comme tous les politiques
publiques ont à ce besoin de règles qui
soient claires de transparence et en
même temps quand même à la fin de la
décision du professionnel qui souveraine
mais dès l'instant où elle est dans un
cadre qui a été défini par ce qu'ils
sont dépositaires du suffrage universel
je crois que il n'ya plus d'autres
interventions monsieur michel il n'y a
plus d'autres interventions il me reste
à vous remercier au nom de tous nos
collègues d'avoir bien voulu nous donner
la position de l'assemblée des
départements de france
voilà pour aller travaux de la
commission des lois si vous souhaitez
revoir ses auditions elles sont
disponibles en vod sur notre site
internet publicsenat.fr bonne fin de
journée à tous